hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and today
i will be breaking down aaron's secret
master plan
the plan that he has been carefully
working on throughout the entire four
year time skip
and a plan that is about to change the
entire world forever
in one of my previous attack on titan
videos i explained what happened during
the four year time skip
in the nation of marley and in that
video
i said that if we can get 15 000 likes
i would make a new video explaining what
happened on the island of paradise
during that same time skip since you
guys more than came through with the
likes on that video
here i am to explain everything that
happened during the time skip on the
island of paradise
and how all of that fits into aaron's
world-changing master plan
thank you again for watching our attack
on titan videos it really means a lot
and let's see if we can get this video
to an absolutely crazy
20 000 likes dropping a like takes only
a second but it really means a lot to me
so thank you in advance
and of course if you're new to the
channel or you haven't subscribed yet
make
this the video do you subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn
on all notifications and if you're
hungry for more attack on titan content
you can check out our already large
and growing attack on titan video
playlist
i will link the entire playlist at the
top of the description and in the pinned
comments so check it out finally this
video will contain
attack on titan manga spoilers as of the
making of this video
aaron's plan hasn't been fully revealed
in the anime so with that said
please proceed with caution you have
been warned
right before the time skip the survey
core on parodies had managed to
eliminate the titan threat beyond the
walls
and they were able to reach the ocean
for the first time
but after everything that they went
through with the marland warrior
infiltration of the walls
aaron and the survey corps knew that
what awaits them on the other side of
that ocean
was not freedom thanks to the basement
revelations
they now knew that just across the sea
is the nation of marley
a mortal enemy of the aldians on
paradise and a dangerous threat to the
very survival
of everyone who lives on the island the
marland warriors had infiltrated the
walls before
and as we know these infiltrators caused
untold death and suffering on the island
with the use of their titan shifter
powers
and it is highly likely that these
marlenes will return to parodies and
attack
once again it was only a matter of time
they want the founding titan they want
the natural resources that the island
has to offer and if we're being honest
they hate the so-called island devils
so much that at some point in the future
the marlins will almost certainly
attempt to kill
every ldn on the island in fact over the
course of the time skip
marley sent 32 scouting ships to
parodies to gather
intel on the islanders and their
movements however
none of these ships ever returned to
marley because they were intercepted by
aaron's attack titan and armin's
colossal titan
the ships were either captured or
destroyed outright
but none of them ever made it back to
marley it is important to note that some
of the marlene soldiers from the
captured ships
actually switched sides and defected to
the side of parodies
this is because many of those soldiers
were not native marlenes
they were in the marlan military because
their own nations were subjugated by
marlei
and so they were compelled to become
soldiers for a nation they
actively opposed that said there are
actual
native marlins like yelena and nicolo
who ended up allying with the forces on
parodies in one way or another
all of these marlene defectors shared
important intel with the aldians on
parodies
including information about marley's
military plans and their modern
technology
during the time skip the paradise forces
also made contact with kiomi
azumabito who is the ambassador of
hizuru hizuru is a nation somewhere in
the far
east of the attack on titan world and it
is that world's equivalent
of japan at various times during the
time skip kiyomi met with both
zeke and the aldians on parodies zeke
secretly tells her that his real goal
is to help free the aldean people and
then
once she arrives on the island of
paradise kyomi's goal is to form a
secret alliance between the nation of
hizuru
and paradise itself historically hizuru
had actually been
allied with the aldian empire and they
are the only known nation that doesn't
actively hate
aldians in fact the two nations were so
close
that a son of hizuru's then ruling
shogun clan
ended up moving to the island of
paradise along with carl fritz some 100
years ago
this son of the shogun clan from hizuru
later started a family on paradise
and that family became the asian clan
inside the walls
mikasa's mother and mikasa herself are
descendants
of this hizuru noble family because of
their historic alliance with the hated
eldians
the hizuru nation suffered greatly after
the fall of eldia
in the great titan war the other nations
resented hizuru for being
allied to their enemies and so hizuru
lost
its power and influence as such kiyomi
hopes that an alliance with paradise
will help restore
hizuru to greatness especially because
paradise possesses important
natural resources that hizuru wants to
get their hands on
by the way kiyomi is also a descendant
of the same hizuru noble family as
mikasa
and that family is currently known as
the azumabito family
during the time skip the islanders on
paradise
used their newfound knowledge of modern
technology to construct a modern railway
line on paradise island
this railway line will end up being a
very important resource in the fight
against marley
because it will allow the islanders to
transport important resources
keep tabs on the island and the
coastline and move their troops far
quicker and easier than before now
throughout the time skip
armin and many of the other survey corps
members are trying to figure out a way
to
end the conflict with marlei
diplomatically
they want to find some peaceful solution
that would allow paradise
marlei and the other nations of the
world to co-exist peacefully
however aaron himself is very skeptical
especially after hizuru fails to secure
additional allies for parodies the rest
of the world still sees ldns and
aldians on the island in particular as
devils and
so aaron is convinced that any attempt
to find a peaceful solution will fail
and it will just lead to the destruction
of paradise and everyone on it including
his closest friends
aaron's belief is only strengthened when
several members of the survey corps
aaron included infiltrate the mainland
in secret in an attempt to meet with
kiomi
and forge new alliances on the continent
while secretly visiting the mainland
aaron recognizes certain things from his
father's memories
which he had inherited through the
attack titan but he remains
cold and distant for most of the trip
while the other members of the survey
corps are hopeful at the prospect of
exploring this new land
and forming new alliances that could
potentially avert
a disaster aaron is not hopeful or
optimistic
in the least this is definitely not the
same errand that we met
at the beginning of the story a boy who
would have been incredibly excited to
explore this
new world beyond the walls for the first
time at one point during this trip
aaron and the other members of the
survey corps attend an important meeting
by world
leaders this summit was actually called
to address the issue of the world's
mistreatment of the ldn population and
so the survey corps members were hoping
that they could win over allies
at this summit and find a peaceful
solution to the conflict between
parodies and the rest of the world
unfortunately it turns out that the
leaders of this summit have the
complete opposite idea they want to
improve the status of the aldians on the
continent by convincing the world to
focus
all of their hatred for aldians towards
the ldns on parodies
in particular essentially they want the
audience outside of parodies to be seen
as
good aldeans while the aldeans on
parodies should be the only ones
seen as evil devils so in theory
after the world unites attacks parodies
and eliminates
all the so-called devils on the island
then the world can be at peace
and the aldians on the continent can
stop being mistreated because the real
threat
the island devils has been eliminated
after hearing this nonsense aaron leaves
the summit
and his mind is made up for good he
eventually meets with yelena in secret
during a celebration in tross district
back on paradise
and during that meeting yelena tries to
convince aaron to support
zeke's master plan zeke's plan is to
euthanize the entire alden race by using
the founding titan to take away their
ability to reproduce
zeke believes that because ldns have the
ability to transform into titans
they will always be seen as a threat to
the world and so as a result
they will always be hated by the rest of
the world and the conflict will keep
going
zeke believes that the world would be
better off if the ldn people simply
stopped
existing and he thinks that the most
humane way to achieve this is to allow
the current generation of aldians to
live out their lives in peace
but to ensure that future generations of
ldn's will never be born
aaron pretends to go along with zeke's
plan at first
but in reality he was opposed to it from
the beginning and this is something that
he privately revealed to flock
aaron needs zeke's help to access the
founding titan powers since zeke has
loyal blood
but aaron has no intention of
euthanizing the aldean people
aaron's real plan is to use the founding
titan to initiate the rumbling and
destroy the entire world
outside of parodies he believes that
this is the only way to save everyone on
the island from being killed by the
marlands
and other nations of the world even
though this plan
involves killing many innocent civilians
outside of the island
people who have nothing to do with the
mistreatment of ldns or the attacks on
parodies
aaron is convinced that this has to be
done
either he destroys the rest of the world
now or
everyone he ever loved and cared about
on the island will eventually be killed
by the outside forces several people
closest to aaron including armin mikasai
and historia
actively oppose this idea but aaron
dismisses their objections and he is
willing to take
all the blame and all the guilt upon
himself
he even considers using the founding
titan to erase everyone's memories of
the rumbling once it does
eventually occur so that they won't have
to feel bad about what aaron did
aaron then goes on to infiltrate marlei
again this time pretending to be a
soldier who had been
injured during the war between marley
and the mideast alliance
on this false pretense and using the
name aaron krueger
aaron eventually makes contact with zeke
aaron convinces zeke that he intends to
support his euthanasia plan
and zeke agrees to help aaron take down
the tiber family and the marlayan
military high command who have all
gathered in liberio
they were all there to announce the new
invasion of parodies
something that zeke himself had pushed
for and the fact that the tiber family
was present is also something that zeke
had ensured
after the devastating battle of liberio
zeke travels back to paradise with aaron
and the survey corps members
hanji is actually angry at aaron for
essentially forcing the survey corps
into supporting his plan in liberio
but aaron is convinced that he has made
the right decision and that the attack
on the barrio has bought the islanders
time to get strong enough to defend
themselves
in reality though aaron's idea of
self-defense is just
utterly destroying the world beyond
parodies but he doesn't reveal that
until later when the survey corps gets
back to paradise
aaron is imprisoned for his unilateral
actions
hanji and many others believe that
aaron's decision to attack liberio has
only increased the world's hatred
towards everyone on parodies
but aaron believes that the hatred was
already there and he only did what he
had to do
eventually aaron escapes from his
underground prison using the warhammer
titans powers
and he and zeke managed to overthrow the
military government on parodies with the
help of the jaegerists
and the jaegerists are a faction of
soldiers who believe that aaron is the
only one who can save parodies from
utter destruction
after aaron and zeke finally managed to
unlock the founding titan's power
they find themselves in the world of the
paths with none other than the
progenitor emir fritz herself
here at last aaron reveals to zeke that
he was never really going to go along
with the euthanasia plan
aaron doesn't want to sterilize the
aliens he wants to save them
at least the ones on parodies zeke
thought that aaron's actions were just
the result of him being brainwashed by
his father grisha
but in reality aaron has always believed
in taking away the freedom of anyone who
wants to take away his own
aaron explains that for the past four
years he has had
access to future memories the attack
titan's special ability is allowing the
current user to see the memories of
future users which is why aaron krueger
somehow knew
about armin and mikasa before they were
even born
in that same way aaron was able to see
grisha's memories from back when he
was the attack titan and that meant that
aaron could also see the memories of the
future that grisha had seen
memories of what aaron himself would end
up doing
in the future these memories of the
future have been guiding aaron's actions
throughout the entire time skip
and it is in part because of these
future memories that aaron gave up on
the idea of finding
a peaceful solution he knew that a
deadly showdown was inevitable
and he decided that if war death and
suffering must
occur then they would occur at the
expense of the outside world
not at the expense of parodies island
aaron's plan was to convince the
progenitor emir fritz to stop obeying
the orders of the members of the royal
bloodline
and join forces with him instead
together they can destroy the outside
world
thereby removing all threats to parody's
island and saving everyone on the island
from inevitable destruction
together they can break this endless
cycle of war
death and revenge this plan has been in
the making
for 2 000 years to you
2 000 years from now and this
is the plan that seems destined to
unfold in the finale
of the attack on titan story aaron's
dilemma
in these final stages of attack on titan
reminds me of a short film from the
czech republic
called most which means the bridge in
this film
a man whose job it is to raise and lower
a drawbridge
faces an incredibly tragic choice while
the bridge is
raised and therefore unusable a train is
approaching it
earlier than it was supposed to arrive
and as this is happening
the man's own son becomes trapped inside
the drawbridge's gears
the father now has to decide whether to
lower the drawbridge
and kill his own son or whether to save
his son and leave the drawbridge
up if he doesn't lower the drawbridge
his son will live but the train will
plunge off the bridge
leading to the deaths of dozens if not
hundreds of people
in the end the father decides to lower
the bridge
he saves the passengers on the train but
his actions
kill his own son however aaron would not
make that choice aaron chooses to save
the people closest
to him the people he loves even if that
means the death of a far greater number
of other people
if the world is determined to destroy
parodies
then aaron will destroy the world
instead even if that leads to the deaths
of millions of innocent people
those people might be innocent but they
are strangers to aaron
and he doesn't feel responsible for
protecting them but he does
feel responsible for protecting his
loved ones and that is exactly what he
is determined
to do aaron has received and will
continue to receive a lot of criticism
for his actions
both in the world of attack on titan and
in our own world
people will condemn him for killing so
many innocent civilians just to protect
his
own people but here's the question
what choice would you make in that exact
situation
if it's either kill or be killed as
aaron believes that it is
would you really sacrifice your own
loved ones just to save
complete strangers would you really just
sit back and watch
as everyone you've ever known and loved
is wiped
out by foreign invaders could you do
that
knowing full well that you have the
power to prevent it
once you move beyond the utilitarian
generalities
and once you really put yourself in
aaron's shoes
are you sure 100 sure that you wouldn't
do exactly
what he did that is a fascinating
question
and that is what makes aaron such a
fascinating character
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more attack on titan content
right here on the channel please leave a
like to let me know
it really does help also if you're new
to the channel or maybe you haven't
subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you really have to go
through the trouble
of hitting that bell and then selecting
the option that says all
i know it's annoying it's an extra step
but if you don't do that you're still
gonna miss a ton of our videos even if
you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works don't forget
to check out our growing attack on titan
playlist
link in the description a big thank you
to all of our anime outpour patrons for
making videos like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma
disciple of lord twego himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who stand above
all other clans including ingrata the
world acquired respect liam thompson
pate hepha rathee and yx
phoenix anime emperor otaku thomas jones
spidey life chanel
big buddhist tungsten tarkis and denki
kaminari
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
steelers on hell cruz anatoly kazatsky
cricket xp
joe stanton very gucci jessica calefon
alicia octor bonnie parks hinokamian
water the red-haired raven florian
joanne garcia jack watches anime fat boy
games
manwa freaks deadly saint matthew cruz
and anthony schreiber
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar gives
you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you